[Música]
vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Juan Pablo lucumi Juan Pablo
actualizamos la información acá estamos
otra vez Ángela empezamos en Argentina
la vicepresidenta de ese país hizo duras
críticas al fmi en el mismo evento en el
que veíamos en el informativo que dijo
que ya había hecho suficiente y que ya
no más candidaturas así es ahora vamos a
las a las declaraciones económicas que
ella dio porque ella no es la única que
critica al acuerdo que hizo el país de
refinanciar su deuda sino pues que
también hay movimientos sociales
políticos e incluso simpatizantes del
presidente Alberto Fernández que han
llenado las calles para señalar al
organismo internacional Esta vez fue
Cristina Fernández de kirchner la que
dijo que gran parte de la inflación del
país se debe a este acuerdo en marzo el
país del cono Sur alcanzó el 104,3%
interanual siendo el segundo mes
consecutivo que supera el 100%, esto en
temas de la inflación y catalogándose
como uno de los principales países que
de la región con datos inflacionarios
tan altos escuchemos lo que dijo la
vicepresidenta en Argentina
digo y sigo sosteniendo que ese acuerdo
ese acuerdo que se firmó con el fondo
monetario internacional es inflacionario
por qué es una política enlatada
enlatada que se aplica como una receta
monotemática a todos los países
Un gobierno constitucional voló por los
aires cinco presidentes en una semana
muertos en las calles de la ciudad de
Buenos Aires represión miseria dolor
entonces creo que
es necesario
revisar
esas cláusulas
ese acuerdo vamos a hacer un cambio de
tema porque ayer se conoció el dato que
mide Cómo está la economía de Estados
Unidos Cómo le fue Ángela no le fue nada
bien a la primera Economía del mundo
Tuvo una brusca desaceleración en el
primer trimestre de 2023 y revisaremos
los datos a continuación Porque todos
estos datos son trimestrales en de Julio
a septiembre tuvo un 3,2% luego ya en
octubre a diciembre un 2,6% aquí se
empezaba a ver la desaceleración para
este año para este primer trimestre hubo
una previsión del
1,9%, esto según economistas de
bloomberg pero tampoco llegó a este dato
no llegó a la previsión sino que alcanzó
un 1,1% entre enero y marzo de pues
estos datos que salieron el día de ayer
este de crecimiento en el pib ocurre
mientras la inflación va en descenso
desde el máximo que alcanzó el año
pasado cuando llegó a su nivel más alto
en cuatro décadas en marzo alcanzó el 5%
interanual pero todavía está lejos del
objetivo del 2% de reserva Federal pero
revisemos otros datos que vinieron
acompañados con el dato del pib el gasto
del consumidor que representa alrededor
del 70% de la actividad económica de
Estados Unidos se mantuvo firme
creciendo a un ritmo anual del 3,7% uno
de los mejores una de las mejores tasas
en casi dos años el gasto en bienes en
particular fue sólido aumentó a su ritmo
más rápido desde el segundo trimestre
esto en 2021 siguiendo en la misma línea
Juan Pablo salieron los datos del pib de
la zona Euro Así es la zona Euro creció
solo marginalmente en los primeros tres
meses de 2023 a un ritmo inferior a las
expectativas del mercado tras el
estancamiento a finales del año pasado
esto mostraron los datos preliminares
del viernes el producto interno bruto en
la zona Euro se expandió un 0,1% en el
primer trimestre por debajo de las
expectativas de una cuenta de routers de
un crecimiento del 0,2% En comparación
con el año anterior el crecimiento fue
del 1,3% frente las expectativas del 1,4
Y miraremos entonces cómo le fue por
países aquí tenemos entonces la zona
Euro un crecimiento del 0,1% para la
Unión Europea que ya es el bloque
comunitario político la zona Euro en el
caso de que comparten el euro para este
segundo fue el 0,3%, miremos Irlanda
España y Portugal tuvieron un
crecimiento del 1,6% para Portugal
España para el 0,5 y Francia del 0,2
Italia también creció pero si vemos por
ejemplo el caso de Alemania la primera
economía de Europa no tuvo un
crecimiento fue el 0,0 por ciento esto
después de venir de contracciones
también el caso de Irlanda tuvo un
crecimiento negativo del 2,7% y Bélgica
del 0,4% vamos a hablar de los
indicadores Así es pues Estados Unidos
abrió en negativo Esto hace unos minutos
con sus tres principales indicadores
indicadores por menos de El 1%. las
bolsas en América Latina cerraron mixtas
con Colombia y Argentina números rojos y
en el caso de Argentina con una
significativa pérdida del 2,62% después
de jornadas de ganancias las bolsas
europeas siguen operando en mayoría a la
baja con el dato de crecimiento
económico que acabamos de ver de la zona
Euro y con más expectativas también y
para el cierre recordamos la cifra de
este día pues son los más de 10 mil
millones de dólares en los que se
incrementó la riqueza de Mark Zuckerberg
el creador de Facebook para llegar a los
87.300 millones de dólares en total que
logró luego de que los sólidos reportes
de venta de metaplatos con esto Mark
Zuckerberg sube un escalón en el índice
de multimillonarios de bloomberg y ahora
llega al puesto número 12 cada vez es
más rico absolutamente una locura
Gracias Juan Pablo nos vemos
próximamente